You could perhaps argue some of these--you might have some difference of opinion here,
but I wouldn't say that the bug was in the actual software under test because
the actual software did what it was supposed to do according to specification correctly.
And was there a bug in the acceptability test--well in that the acceptability test didn't check this
then yes but if you're going to use that as a metric, then you could argue that all bugs are bugs
in acceptability test because they didn't catch all of the bugs which is of course infeasible.
I would say this is a bug in the specification because this was a miscommunication
between the engineers at NASA and Lockheed Martin.
And both of their ideas were correct but they didn't communicate those ideas properly.
It was assumed on each of their ends.
So if they had put that information explicitly in this specification then we wouldn't really have
had the issues and the Mars Climate Orbiter wouldn't have had at least that bug
may be something else would cropped up or maybe not.
I also wouldn't say that there is a bug in the underlying OS, compiler, libraries, or hardware.
At least this bug isn't an example of that. At least we don't have any evidence of that.
There might have been other bugs again but this one I would say is definitely a bug
in the specification--so let's check one more example and then move on.